have you spoken to your classmates
new video Raquel Levis all bundled up in
Black and wearing a mask this morning as
she landed at LAX the 28 year old will
attend tomorrow's Vanderpump reunion
taping
you see any reconciliation in the future
our source says Raquel wants to
apologize in person to Ariana Maddox for
her affair with her partner of nine
years Tom Sandoval also heading to La
Bravo hosts Andy Cohen as for Ariana she
just landed an acting role lifetime
announced this afternoon she'll join the
cast of their new original movie bind
back my daughter you don't deserve one
fear of mine are you excited for the
reunion what do you think
the newly single reality star clutched
in iced coffee and threw Raquel some
Mariah level shade has Raquel called to
apologize or anything like that or no
I don't know her I don't know who you're
talking about we're also learning new
details about tomorrow's secret taping
you want anything for you to die they're
taking our phones because there's a leak
no social media posting no behind the
scenes no nothing
the logistics are super tricky because
of this restraining order yes Raquel
accused co-star Sheena Shea of punching
her which Sheena denied still the two
will likely have to film separately and
maintain a distance of 100 yards apart
fan of all said I should set boundaries
and I was like what's the boundary but
here's a question has Ariana already
moved on from Tom a lot of fans wondered
after seeing this skinny dipping shot in
the new mid-season promo it's me hi I am
the one naked in the pool with Ariana
and I am gay so glad we could clear that
up and make sure you guys support my
friend's show on onesies on Bravo
[Music]